and here's the thing it's one thing to
to say it but
um his act because I would like to think
about about this earlier like how do I
because I can say to you like listen
this based off of her presence it's just
like if something was to happen I'd be
like Megan you good
based off the aura in the room or
whatever that changed right so it's just
like how do we get more women into
understanding of like that's what
femininity is I mean ease is I think
it's so rare because it's a failure on
the mother's part I mean even from two
parent households you absolutely see a
lack of femininity in the mothers like
how many how many moms genuinely that
you know if if the husband made a
decision a big decision for the
household that she did not agree with
she would just say okay yes sir